en el año transcurrido del mundo ha
asistido al Gran turbulencia crisis
crecientes de la inseguridad alimentaria
calor sin precedentes
sequías inundaciones Kobe 19 la
inflación
y una guerra necesaria y brutal una
guerra que escogió un hombre para ser
muy Franco
hablemos con franqueza un miembro
permanente del Consejo de Seguridad de
Naciones Unidas invadió a su vecino y
trató de borrar a un estado soberano del
mapa
Rusia de barcos vergonzosamente vulneros
los preceptos sectoriales de la carta de
Naciones Unidas
no menos importante que la prohibición
Clara en contra de que un país se haga
con el territorio de un país por la
fuerza una vez más hoy mismo el
presidente Putin ha hecho otras amenazas
nucleares contra Europa con desprecio
de sus responsabilidades con respecto al
régimen de No proliferación ahora mismo
Rusia
ha pedido que vayan más el soldados al
combate y el kremlin está organizando un
referente
falso para tratar de accionar parte de
Ucrania
que es una casa violación de la carta de
Naciones Unidas el mundo tiene que ver
estos actos horrendos por lo que son
Putin dice que tuvo que actuar porque se
veía amenazada a Rusia pero nadie
amenazó a Rusia
y nadie como no fuera Rusia
buscó el conflicto es más
podríamos alertado que se avecinaba y
hicimos mucho para evitarlo
pero en las palabras
innegable su propósito auténtico justo
antes de invadir Putin dijocito Ucrania
fue creada por Rusia nunca en citó tuvo
un estado real pero ahora vemos
que se ha atacado escuelas estaciones de
ferrocarriles nosocomios
los centros de la cultura historia de
Ucrania en el pasado
hay incluso pruebas más horrendas de la
solidaridad atrocidades y crímenes de
guerra fosas comunes
cuerpos según los que sumaron esos
cuerpos con indicios de tortura esta
guerra
es para extinguir el derecho de Ucrania
de existir como estado así de sencillo y
el derecho de Ucrania de existir como
pueblo
quien quiera que sea donde quiera que
viva a cualquiera que sea su creencia
eso debe hacer sentir escalofríos por
ello Es que 141 naciones en la asamblea
general se reunieron
y de manera inequívoca condenaron la
guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania los
Estados Unidos
enviado asistencia masiva en asistencia
humanitaria y apoyo económico directo a
Ucrania
más de 25 mil millones de dólares a la
fecha
nuestros aliados en el mundo también han
hecho lo propio y ahora
más de 40 países representados aquí
mismo han contribuido con miles de
millones de sus propios recursos y
equipo para ayudar a Ucrania a
defenderse
los Estados Unidos también están
trabajando estrechamente con nuestros
socios y aliados para imponer
un costo arrocea para disuadir atentados
al territorio del otanic para que rinda
cuentas la Rusia por las atrocidades y
crímenes de guerra Porque si las
naciones pueden perseguir la ambiciones
imperialistas sin consecuencias se pone
a riesgo todo lo que estas instituciones
esta institución representa todo
la victoria ganada en el campo de
batalla
se merece reconocimiento a los soldados
ucranianos pero en este año se sometió a
prueba el mundo y no dudamos
escogimos la libertad la soberanía
y los principios en los que todos los
que tiene que ver con la carta se debe
respetar estuvimos con Ucrania al igual
que ustedes los Estados Unidos quiere
que llegue a su fin esta guerra en
términos justos en condiciones que todos
aceptamos pero no puede uno hacerse con
el territorio de una nación a la fuerza
el único país
obstaculiza es Rusia por ello nosotros
cada uno de los aquí presentes en este
recinto que están dispuestos a respetar
las convicciones que nos comprometimos a
defender como Naciones Unidas tenemos
actuar de manera clara y decidida
Ucrania Tiene los mismos derechos que
pertenecen a toda nación soberana
estaremos solidarios con Ucrania y
seríamos solidarios con y obtendremos la
agresión rusa punto y aparte y es un
Secreto a voces que en el contexto entre
autocracia y democracia los Estados
Unidos y yo como su presidente
paladín de la visión de nuestro mundo
arraigado en los valores de la
Democracia los Estados Unidos están
decididos a defender y fortalecer la
democracia en nuestro país en el mundo
entero porque la democracia sigue siendo
el mejor instrumento de la humanidad
para ocuparse de los desafíos de
nuestros tiempos estamos cooperando con
el g7 y países afines para comprobar que
las democracias sí pueden ayudar a los
ciudadanos pero también pueden ayudar al
resto del mundo y ahora es que estamos
reunidos el día de hoy en la carta de
las Naciones Unidas y sus principios de
lograr un mundo justo y estable con
normas se ve atacado por aquellos que
quieren desgarrarla y destruirlo para
sus propias ventajas políticas y la
carta de las Naciones Unidas
no solo la firmaron las democracias en
el mundo se negoció
entre ciudadanos decenas de Naciones con
distintas historias ideologías Unidos en
su compromiso de obrar por la paz
como dijo el presidente truman en 1945
la carta de las Naciones Unidas visitan
es prueba de que las naciones
pueden presentar sus diferencias
afrontarlas y luego llegar a un Común
denominador que acepten se necesita ese
como un denominador era muy directo muy
básico y hoy 193
representantes estados miembros de
manera
han afirmado Estos principios y han
respetado esos principios de la carta de
Naciones Unidas que es una tarea de todo
responsable de estado miembro de
Naciones Unidas rechazo el uso de la
violencia en la guerra para conquistar
naciones o ampliar fronteras y derramar
sangre
lo ponerse a la política mundial del
temor en la coacción y hay que defender
los derechos soberanos naciones más
pequeñas al igual que los de los más
grandes y a principios básicos
como la libertad de navegación Respeto
del derecho internacional el control de
armas no importa cuánto sean nuestras
desavenencias se trata de un punto común
que hay que reafirmar
y Si siguen comprometidos con reducir no
es Pilares en pro de bien de todas las
naciones en el mundo de Estados Unidos
entonces trabajará con ustedes Además
estoy convencido de que llegó el momento
para que esta institución sea una más
inclusiva De modo que pueda responder
mejor a las necesidades del mundo actual
los miembros del Consejo de Naciones
Unidas como los Estados Unidos
deben respetar una y otra vez y defender
la carne Naciones Unidas y abstenerse
abstenerse del uso del veto salvo en
circunstancias extraordinarias porque el
consejo no pierda su creatividad ni
eficacia y por eso también los Estados
Unidos han apoyado el aumentar el número
de miembros permanentes y no permanentes
en el consejo lo cual incluye escaños
permanentes para que las naciones que
hemos apoyado durante mucho tiempo
puestos permanentes para países de
África América Latina y el Caribe los
Estados Unidos se ha comprometido con
este trabajo importante en toda región
hemos insistido en que se busca nuevas
maneras constructivas para trabar con
socios e impulsar intereses comunes
desde el lugar al cuadro en el Pacífico
hasta firmar la declaración de
inmigración y protección en la Cumbre de
las Américas hasta sumarnos a la reunión
histórica de nueve líderes árabes para
trabajar hacia un medio oriente más
integral Pacífico organizando la Cumbre
de líderes de África en diciembre
venidero y como dije el año pasado los
Estados Unidos está dando pasado a una
era de diplomacia incesante para atender
los desafíos que importantes para la
vida de todas las personas lidiar con la
crisis climática como lo dijera el
orador que mientras tiene la palabra
fortalecer la seguridad del Mundial de
la Salud alimentar al mundo alimentarlo
hicimos esa prioridad de un año después
la hemos mantenido como promesa desde el
día en que asumi mi cargo hemos decidido
con
audacia el cambio
nos volvemos al acuerdo climático hemos
concertado acuerdos importantes en cop
26 ayudamos a que dos terceras partes
del pie del mundo volviera a cargarse
para controlar el calentamiento a 1.5
grados celsius y acaba de firmar un
proyecto de ley en los Estados Unidos
histórico que incluye el compromiso
climático más importante que jamás se
haya contraído en la historia de nuestro
país
369 mil millones de dólares para
controlar el cambio climático lo cual
incluye decenas de millones de nuevas
inversiones En energía solar frente a
las costas
promover los vehículos eléctricos
aumentar la eficacia energética apoyar
la fabricación limpia nuestro
departamento de energía Calcula que esta
nueva ley reducir las emisiones
estadounidas a razón de una gigatón al
año para el año 2030 una giga tonelada y
dando lugar a un crecimiento económico
basado en energía limpia nuestras
inversiones también van
tecnologías limpias en el mundo entero
no solo en los Estados Unidos
se trata de algo que cambia los logros
en el mundo y no tenemos tiempo que
perder
todos sabemos que ya estamos ante una
crisis climática
Ya nadie lo pone te la de juicio luego
de los 12 meses transcurridos nos damos
cita
ahora que casi todo Pakistán está
sumergido y necesita ayuda Mientras que
el cuerno de África afronta de una
sequías sin precedentes las familias
afrontan una elección imposible escoger
entre a cual hijo alimentar y se
preguntan si sobrevivirán
es el costo humano que tiene el cambio
climático y que va al alza no a la baja
el año pasado anuncié que para cumplir
nuestra responsabilidad mundial mi
gobierno está cooperando para ofrecer
más de 11.000 millones de dólares al año
al financiamiento Internacional del
cambio climático para ayudar a que los
países cumplan sus objetivos climáticos
nivelar porque hay una transición justa
en el sector energético y la clave será
nuestro plan que ayudará a 500 millones
de personas sobre todo en países
vulnerables
adaptarse ante los impactos del cambio
climático y crear resiliencia
esta necesidad es descomunal y que este
es el momento
tenemos como el mundo va a tratar de
deshacer la devastación en el mundo
y impulsar un economía sostenible Limpia
para preservar el planeta en cuanto a
salud mundial hemos ofrecido más de 620
millones de dosis de la vacuna de Kobe
19 2006 países en el mundo entero y
ellos para atender las necesidades de
los países todo gratuito Sin condiciones
estamos trabajando estrechamente con el
g20 y otros países
con los que ayuda a Estados Unidos a
dirigir el cambio y Establecer un nuevo
fondo para la prevención y preparación
de pandemias con el Banco Mundial y a su
vez
Seguiremos impulsando el trabajo a favor
ante los desafíos de la salud mundial
más tarde hoy voy a organizar la séptima
conferencia de reposición del fondo
mundial para luchar contra el sida
tuberculo y paludismo con el apoyo
partidista en nuestro congreso me
comprometía contribuir hasta 6000
millones de dólares a este trabajo
me interesan entonces recibir muchas
promesas de contribuciones la
conferencia para atender
lograr una de los eventos de recaudación
de fondos más importantes de la historia
También estamos remitiendo contra la
crisis alimentaria con 193 millones de
personas en el mundo que sufren
inseguridad alimentaria aguda repito
aguda Un aumento de 40 millones en un
año hoy anuncio otros
1900 millones de dólares de apoyo
estadounidense para salvar
vidas mediante la asistencia humanitaria
y alimentaria en este año nada más
mientras Rusia está llegando vidas y
tratando de culpar por la crisis
alimentaria a las sanciones que fueron
impuestas por muchos en el mundo debido
a la agresión contra Ucrania
Así que lo voy a decir con todas las
letras nuestras sanciones
de manera explícita permite
Rusia el poder exportar alimentos y
fertilizantes
sin límite alguno es la guerra de Rusia
la que ha grabado la inseguridad puede
terminarla agradezco la labor realizada
aquí en Naciones Unidas incluso por su
líder el señor secretario general al
Establecer un mecanismo para exportar
seriales por los puertos del mal negro
en Ucrania que Rusia había bloqueado
durante meses y hay que asegurarnos de
que se amplíe esa iniciativa nos
retiramos en la comisión desde que hay
que alimentar al mundo
por eso es que los Estados Unidos es el
principal promotor del programa mundial
de alimentos con más de un 40% de su
presupuesto financiado por nosotros y
somos líderes en el apoyo al trabajo de
unicef para alimentar a los niños en el
mundo
y asumir una asumir un desafío mayor los
Estados Unidos hizo un llamado a la
acción con una hoja de ruta para
eliminar la inseguridad alimentaria en
el mundo
y que más de 100 estados miembros lo han
apoyado en junio el g7 anunció más de
4.500 millones de dólares para
fortalecer los programas de seguridad
alimentaria en el mundo entero mediante
usa y de su iniciativa alimentar el
futuro de los Estados Unidos ha
aumentado nuevos programas para
llevar semillas a zonas con sequías para
ayudar a los campesinos que lo necesitan
distribuyendo fertilizantes y mejorando
la eficacia del fertilizante para que la
agricultor pueda cultivar más usando
menos y estamos pidiendo a todos los
países a que se abstengan de prohibir
las exportaciones de alimentos o
acumular cereales porque son tantos los
que sufren porque en todo el país todo
país en el mundo independientemente de
lo que nos divida
si un padre de familia no puede
alimentar a sus hijos
no importa nada más si un padre una
madre no puede alimentar a sus hijos y
con ellas al futuro estamos en
cooperación con nuestros socios para
crear normas ante los nuevos desafíos
del Siglo 21
se inició el consejo de comercio
tecnológico en la Unión Europea para
asegurarnos de que las tecnologías
principales las clave se produzcan Y
reglamenten de modo que se reúnen el
beneficio de todos con nuestros socios
amigos y Naciones Unidas estamos
fortaleciendo las normas de
responsabilidad y la conducta
responsable de los estados en el
ciberespacio y queremos hacer que rindan
cuentas aquellos que usan atentados
ciber atentados amenazando la paz y la
cebras internacionales con socios en las
Américas África Europa y el medio
oriente en lo Pacífico estamos
Estableciendo un nuevo ecosistema
económico
en donde todas las naciones tiene
una oportunidad justa en cuanto al
crecimiento resiliente económico
sostenido por eso es que Estados Unidos
es paladín del impuesto mínimo mundial y
hablaremos porque se realice de modo que
las empresas principales contribuyan lo
propio por doquier
también hay una idea en el marco
lindo Pacífico que Estados Unidos empezó
este año con otras tres economías de la
región estamos cooperando con nuestros
socios en el Asia y en las islas del
Pacífico Para apoyar una visión
ejemplo de una región Indo pacífica
crítica abierta conectada próspera
asegurada resiliente junto con los
socios en el mundo entero
queremos crear cadenas de suministro
resistentes para proteger a todos ante
la cohesión o la dominación y
asegurarnos de que ningún país use la
energía como arma Y a medida que sigue
la guerra de Rusia asolándole la
economía mundial también pedimos a los
acreedores en el mundo incluso los que
no forman parte del club de París a que
negocian transparentemente la coronación
de la deuda para los países de bajos
ingresos y que
eviten otras crisis en el mundo con
problemas que no impongan deudas a los
jóvenes atendamos las necesidades en
materia de infraestructura en el mundo
con inversiones transparentes con
proyectos de altas normas protegiendo
los derechos laborales y el medio
ambiente atendiendo las necesidades de
las comunidades
Y no y por eso Estados Unidos junto con
socios del g7 empezó en la asociación
para la infraestructura mundial y la
inversión mundial pretendemos como
colectivos movilizar
600 billones de dólares en esta Alianza
para el año 2017 decenas de proyectos se
ya se han iniciado
fabricación de vacunas
Industrial en senegal proyectos solares
en Angola primero en su género es una
central nuclear en romania son
inversiones que tendrán rayitos no solo
para esos países sino para todos los
Estados Unidos va a cobrar con todas las
naciones e incluso en nuestros
competidores para resolver problemas
mundiales como el cambio climático
la diplomacia del clima No es un favor
para los Estados Unidos ni ninguna otra
nación y el distanciarse
afecta al mundo entero
en cuanto a la competencia entre Estados
Unidos y China
Al haber tendencias cambiantes
geopolíticas Estados Unidos se va a
comportar como un líder Sensato no
pretendemos Buscar conflictos ni una
guerra fría No pedimos a ninguna nación
que escoja entre los Estados Unidos
o ningún otro socio pero los Estados
Unidos
será sincero al poner una visión de un
mundo libre seguro próspero y lo que
tenemos que ofrecer a las comunidades y
Naciones inversiones
cuyo diseño no es fomentar dependencias
sino aliviar las cargas y ayudar a las
naciones a que lleguen a ser
autosuficientes alianzas no para creer
obligaciones políticas Pero porque
sabemos que nuestro propio éxito cada
uno de nuestros éxitos aumenta también
el de otras naciones cuando las personas
tienen la oportunidad de vivir en
dignidad
y fomentar sus talentos todos se
benefician muy importante es estar a la
altura de los objetivos nobles de esa
institución aumentar la paz y seguridad
para todos por doquier
los Estados Unidos determinación
de seguir haciendo que se rindan cuentas
por las amenazas terroristas del mundo
dirigiremos
en encontrar soluciones pacíficas y en
cuanto y Seguimos comprometidos con
nuestra una única una sola china que ha
pedido los conflictos y no queremos que
cambien status quo por nadie apoyamos
una Unión africana un proceso de paz
para acabar con las luchas en Etiopía
dirigido por la unión africana y en
Venezuela
y hay más de 6 millones de personas que
han tenido que abandonar el país
debe haber un diálogo dirigido por los
venezolanos y volver a que haya
elecciones justas y libres y también hay
gran violencia y enormes crisis humanas
en otros países y exhortamos al mundo
hacerlo lo mismo es más lo que tenemos
que hacer
y con una tregua medida por las Naciones
Unidas en yemen para que haya una que
permite que haya una paz valiosísima
para personas que han sufrido con años
de violencia y seguimos premiando una
negociación duradera para la paz entre
el pueblo palestino y el estado de
Israel o los Estados Unidos están
comprometidos con la seguridad de Israel
punto de la negociación de los dos
estados sigue siendo para nosotros la
mejor forma de que haya prosperidad y
seguridad en Israel para el futuro y
para que los palestinos tengan el estado
al que tienen derecho ambas partes
deben respetar cabalmente los derechos
igualitarios de sus ciudadanos ambos
pueblos deben demostrar de disponer de
la misma libertad de dignidad y estamos
también a todas las naciones a que
vuelvan a comprometerse a reforzar el
régimen de no proliferación nuclear a
través de la diplomacia
lo que quiera que ocurre en el mundo
pese a ello los Estados Unidos van a
seguir persiguiendo las medidas de
control una guerra nuclear no se puede
ganar y nunca se debe librar
los cinco miembros permanentes del
Consejo de Seguridad de reiterar su
compromiso en enero lo hicieron en enero
pero hoy vemos que hay tendencias
preocupantes Rusia
acabó con los ideales de no
proliferación
de la décima conferencia de examen del
tnp y digo de nuevo
que están haciendo amenazas y
responsables de utilizar armas nucleares
china ha llevado a cabo
un desarrollo de la energía nuclear sin
transparencia pese a los esfuerzos para
que haya una diplomacia sostenida la
República popular democrática de Corea
sigue violando flagrantemente las
sanciones de las Naciones Unidas los
Estados Unidos están preparados a que
haya Un regreso al plan de acción
conjunto completo para que se cumplan
las obligaciones de Irán los Estados
Unidos lo tienen claro nosotros no vamos
a permitir que Irán se haga con un arma
nuclear Sigo creyendo que la diplomacia
es la mejor forma de conseguir todo esto
el
régimen de no proliferación es uno de
los grandes éxitos de esta institución
no podemos dejar que el mundo de Un paso
atrás tampoco podemos hacer caso omiso
al socavamiento los Derechos Humanos
es uno de los grandes logros el de la
declaración universal de los Derechos
Humanos
a partir de lo cual nuestros antecesores
dijeron que teníamos que medirnos en
1948 dejaron Claro que los Derechos
Humanos son la base para todo lo que
queremos conseguir y sin embargo hoy en
2022 las libertades fundamentales están
en peligro en todo el mundo
desde las violaciones
los recientes detallados de la oficina
informes del alto comisionado y Los
Terribles
abusos sobre los que defienden
los Derechos Humanos por parte del
ejército en birmania y también la
represión en Afganistán de las mujeres
por parte de los talibanes y Hoy estamos
con los valientes ciudadanos las
las valientes mujeres de Irán que están
velando por sus derechos básicos Y esto
es lo que yo sé el futuro se ganará lo
ganarán los países que
aprovechen todos los potenciales de su
población donde las mujeres y las niñas
puedan ejercer los derechos igualitarios
Como los derechos básicos reproductivos
y hay economías fuertes
y sociedades más resilientes donde las
minorías religiosas y étnicas puedan
vivir sin agua se puedan contribuir al
tejido de sus comunidades donde la
comunidad lgbt
q más pueda no ser objeto de violencia
donde los ciudadanos puedan cuestionar
criticar a sus líderes sin miedo a la
represalia los Estados Unidos siempre
van a promover los derechos humanos y
Valora lo consagrado en la carta de las
Naciones Unidas lo haremos en nuestro
país y en todo el mundo acabaré diciendo
que esta institución
guiada por la carteras Naciones Unidas y
la declaración universal de Derechos
Humanos
tiene como es un acto de Esperanza
inquebrantable lo decimos una vez más es
un acto de Esperanza inquebrantable
piensen en la visión de esos primeros
delegaciones cuando emprendieron la
tarea que parecía imposible de que
hubiera en un mundo que todavía humeaba
piensen En cómo
qué violencia debe haber sufrido los
pueblos del mundo con esa llorando a los
millones muertos con esos horrores del
holocausto tenían todo el derecho de
pensar lo peor de la humanidad y sin
embargo
quisieron arraigarse en lo mejor de
nosotros para construir algo mejor una
paz duradera la calma entre las naciones
los Derechos Humanos para todos los
miembros de la familia humana la
cooperación para el avance de los seres
humanos
líderes el reto que enfrentamos hoy sin
duda es ingente pero nuestras
capacidades son mayores nuestro
compromiso debe ser todavía mayor así
que juntos
declaremos
la resolución
inquebrantable de las Naciones del mundo
unidas que defendemos los valores de la
carta de las Naciones Unidas que
seguimos creyendo que trabajando juntos
podemos
acabar con el miedo para que hay un
mundo más justo para todos nuestros
niños